[Music]
know
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet d value taming giving values
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we get no value to haters run homie look
what I become I'm the I'm the
one okay so there's an epidemic going on
in the NFL with fans that we got to
figure this thing out right now and
correct it before it's too late it's not
Terell Owens it's Terrell Owens say it
Terell ter like Cheryl Terell Owens is
the proper pronunciation not Terrell and
by the way I'm speaking to myself cuz I
called him Terrell before he walked and
let me properly introduce Our Guest
today although many of you if you follow
Sports if you love sports you definitely
know who this man is he's a Hall of
Famer uh I was glad when it happened
although a lot of people would say was
well overdue but uh third alltime I
think in yards touchdowns uh eight in
regular season receptions 1078 15934
yards 150 touchdowns 153 and the only
player ever to catch a touchdown with
every single NFL team this is according
to ESPN was inducted into the Hall of
Fame in 2018 and on top of that a a
recently on my birthday was reported
that a car hit him and was absolutely
damaged I'm sorry I'm reading the story
the other way Ron you know Terrell hit
the car and Terrell hit the car the car
is suing P the car is Su the car is up
it's injured it's got a lawyer the car
is a lawyer it is great to have you on
the podcast man appreciate it thank you
guys for having me yeah it's very good
to have you on the podcast uh it's it's
interesting you know as a fan we're
sitting here talking Tom uh says uh you
were at the last game right you were at
Jerry Rice's last game yeah my wife is
Niner faithful man Niner faithful and uh
if they didn't want you to break the
record why did they keep throwing it to
you that's the one where you get 20
catches I think Jerry's Record was what
16 and you know it was against was it
against the Bears or against the Bears
it was a talk of town because it was
supposed to be shut him out yeah yeah
but but anyway so everybody has a
terrible story of
watching you you know I got a couple
other questions I want to get into
obviously you know the Stephen A SMI
Smith stuff that we got to get into
we'll get into that in a minute we'll
talk about Courier we'll talk about
football we'll talk about today we'll
talk about uh fastest we'll talk about a
few different things but uh very
open-ended question for you for as a guy
that maybe is a fan of the game of
course I saw you with Dion the other day
we have to talk about Dion as well do do
you like today's game more than the game
you used to play in or the game even
before you which game do you like more
uh from what I watch um again the the
game is a little bit less physical um
obviously I think that's why you have an
inflation of receiver yards and catches
um obviously they've kind of minimized
that kind of like the defensive uh
aggressiveness of of the defense um but
I'm a basketball fan at heart so I don't
really watch a lot of football and it's
probably surprising to a lot of people
that that ask me the same question that
you're asking me when I grew up uh in
Alabama I was raised by my Grandmama and
my mama um I wasn't really into sports
like that I played a lot of sports but I
didn't ever think that I would play at
the professional level or reach the
level that I did so I only watch
football occasionally now with guys that
were playing while I was playing and
some of the guys that I've run into run
across uh probably over the last four or
five years that have entered into the
league like uh DK matf for example um
still talk to Julio Jones he just got
acquired uh just got back on the uh in
NFL and he's playing with the
Philadelphia Eagles guys that I've
worked out with over the last few years
or so so um that's that's kind of like
my involvement and then obviously
obviously with social media um I stay
kind of like a breast of what's going on
um around the league I mean I have a
number of friends that are either
Cowboys fans they're Eagle fans or
they're San Francisco 49ers fans as a
matter of fact last night I had two two
of those guys on the phone uh they
FaceTime me last night um a 49er fan and
a guy that's an Eagles fan and for the
last three to four weeks they've been
calling me kind of asking me like my
take on who's going to win why are they
going to win things of that nature so uh
my 49er fan he's having a tough time
right now because he friend he's cuz
they've lost three in a row and I kind
of gave them gave them a heads up and I
tell them like look I'm not really
invested in it cuz I see it from a
different perspective than fans so I
honestly I give my honest assessment as
to what I think going to happen in the
game you know why are they going to win
or why they may lose and so I've been
pretty much I'm batting a thousand right
now and my my Eagles guy he's on Cloud9
right now eight and one they just had a
very good Cowboys played good but they
had a very good game what is their
record five and three or five and four
no no the uh the Eagles eight and one
eight and one number 81 here
yeah yeah so if anybody wants the pick
for next week hang on cuz T's going
eight and one so by the way what do you
think about this whole conversation
about a lot of guys that you know post
Brady they like kind of want to get uh
connected with the next Brady what do
you think about this conversation that
pry has what it takes you know Underdog
you know wasn't drafted that high nobody
really banked on this guy his parents
even brought him there not thinking he's
going to play he's got a very good
Underdog Story do you think that is a
little bit too much hype or do you think
he has the goodies showns the signs that
he can be a player like that I mean I
think when you look at what he did last
year taking over um and
obviously winning a lot of games and got
him to the Super Bowl and then obviously
unfortunately for him he got hurt in the
Super Bowl so we we we don't know what
would have happened but based on what we
saw leading up to that I mean they very
well could have won the Super Bowl um
but then you start this season out
you're starting out hot and then the
last three games you know you kind of
feel like okay maybe defenses are
catching on to him um they've done done
a lot of film study they're kind of
choosing to see what his strengths and
weaknesses are and defense maybe
defensive coordinators maybe are trying
to to expose those or exploit those uh I
mean so uh right now I think if you look
at what he's done he's definitely
capable of playing in this league I
think when you think about the Tom Brady
you start to mention guys like Tom Brady
what makes those guys great
is the consistency um of their play and
I think that's what's in question right
now especially within the last three
games you ever caught Brady's passes
like even just like Pro Bowl in any have
you and Brady ever caught a pass to like
have you actually I did um he was um I
was in Los Angeles I can't remember what
year it was it might have been like
around
20 maybe 14 to 15 maybe and uh he was uh
working out with one of his trainers Tom
house at uh USC and uh we ran I ran a
few routes and stuff out there with uh
with him and some other receivers in a
in a in a running route like that can
you get a feel and say damn that was
okay so this is why he is always or is
it so much more about discipline
consistency and mindset that you don't
sense the difference between him or Romo
or Garcia or young or McNab you're like
no I definitely felt the difference with
Brady well you can know you know the
difference between a catchable ball um
and like a guy that throws with finesse
knows when to throw with a little little
zip little velocity uh on it um I would
tend to more give you a better
assessment in game in a in a game
setting or or a practice setting because
now he has to figure out understand my
run gate how I come in and how I
transition in and out of my routes my
speed all those things um in a in a
practice setting and a competitive
setting um that's when you kind of feel
get a feel for what a quarterback can
and cannot do but when it comes to game
time situation when you look at and I
was just mentioning this to the guys too
last night um when you think about the
game that uh the Super Bowl that they
won coming back from what 25 down
against the ATA Atlanta Falcons 283 yeah
something like that um when you think
about that game the error the margin of
error is really really small especially
being down that many points so you have
to understand with a guy like that you
have to be very cerebral to understand
the matchups you have to
know when and where to throw the ball
with uh again ball placement um and then
you have to pick your match ups
obviously the plays have to be called
but you have to execute those plays and
for Tom like I said being down that many
points you have to maximize every
opportunity to get back into the ball
game and then there another thing to
actually win it so when you think about
what he did in that game it's remarkable
because
you have to look at I can't remember
know the receivers that were on the team
at that time but you have to understand
like every down and distance every play
matters exactly and you got to
understand the matchups that that that
that are on the field when you think
about the gronowski I think maybe
elderman was there um you have to pick
your battles and understand on this down
and distance like who's over here who's
over there you have to manipulate the
defense like whether it's cover one
cover two uh you have to manipulate the
defense with your eyes and your feet and
he was able able to do that when you
think about just the accuracy and just
the the velocity and where he puts the
ball that that that's a lot let let me
ask you as a receiver I don't know what
it is to be you know uh one of the
greatest receivers in some arguments the
greatest receiver all time right do you
know if you can't see the quarterback
throwing the ball do you know just by
catching and the way the ball comes who
it is like with the guys you played
could you tell that's a Garcia pass
that's a young pass that's you can do
that well from a right right-handed
quarterback and a left-handed
quarterback yes that was something that
I had to get adjusted to because for so
many years I've always caught
right-handed quarterbacks but then when
I got with the
49ers I had left sense way ball is
spinning yeah I had Steve Young and then
I think I may have dropped the ball a
couple of times when it came to me I'm
like it just hits the hands differently
um it's a different rotation on on on
the ball so those are things you have to
get adjusted to you're want to say that
about Steve Young everybody there's a
lot of receivers that really respected
playing with him oh I didn't see you
over here my bad hey Tom hey how are you
what's going on Tom's creped up on you
he's getting back at me there's a lot of
receivers that said when they they had
to learn to play Steve Young they said
you could trust him because the ball was
going to be there and he had good
Finance good placement everything you're
talking about but the ball spun
different y especially if it was a
little wet and they said that that was
that took getting used to well yeah I
mean
that's as a receiver like I said it
wasn't something that I thought about
but then I knew when I when I ran the
route and the ball hit my hands I knew
something was different um and obviously
when you think about the West Coast
offense um everything is based on timing
and precision um that's why I'm so
fortunate and I'm grateful to have been
number one drafted to the Niners but
then I got a chance to watch another
great athlete of all time in Jerry Rice
um who played the position that I again
like I said I end up you know kind of
you know shattering some of his records
but um I got a chance to to watch him
and
so I I couldn't have been in a better
situation uh coming from a small school
UT Chattanooga um and then obviously
like I said playing like I said I was I
I I was drafted to to to a team
obviously that had future Hall of Famers
in that room um and you think about said
obviously uh Jerry Rice and then
obviously Steve Young um again these two
honestly kind of help unfold uh who I
was as a receiver and unfortunately I
didn't get to get to play the entirety
or the majority of my career with Steve
Young obviously due to you know the
concussions um but I only got got to
play three years with Steve Young and
then obviously uh Jeff Garcia came in
and then I played with a pleora of
quarterbacks I mean Elvis gerbach I mean
um Tim rate um there are so many uh
quarterbacks that I played with but who
who's to I I honestly I wish I I don't
know what I could have accomplished had
I had Steve Young for eight years I was
just going to ask you who who was out of
all them T out of all the quarterbacks
game time passing everything all the way
who do you think was the best one to
throw to you game time i h i people ask
me this and they think I'm being funny
but I I love Ryan Fitzpatrick wow I I I
do and I played with a number of
quarterback but if you think about if
you think about Ryan Fitzpatrick's
career interesting he was never he was
never with a team for a long period of
time where he was the main state that
started he always came in he filled in
but he played very very well um so
obviously like I said there's a number
of quarterbacks obviously that I played
with um that obviously could I could
give a nod to but again I look at late
in my career especially in Buffalo
because that was like my first stint
with him and Trent Edwards was the the
the quarterback at that at that time and
so they brought me in and they was like
okay we need you to come in and kind of
help groom this guy and so obviously for
him some injuries came uh came into play
uh he had his main guys that he was
throwing to um and it's hard like I said
I was that was later on in my career but
I knew I could still play the game but
he had somewhat of a u a comfort level
with the guys that were already there
Lee Evans uh Josh uh I think Josh Reed
not was it Josh Reed I don't know some
other uh receivers that were there that
he was comfortable with and so I didn't
really get a chance to really evolve and
really play like I wanted to play until
Ryan fatrick took over at quarterback
and I started to just play like
everybody expected me to play he's a dog
though he's a he's a he's a Fitzpatrick
is a oh yeah absolutely feisty guy rally
players from obviously from a fans
perspective it looked like players liked
playing with him I don't know what he
was like in the locker room but there
was something attractive about his
personality no no he he's a he's a
baller he's a gamer um and again he's
very very he's tough um again obviously
smart guy um where he went to Harvard he
went to Harvard economic ecomic student
at Harvard hysterical interviews
afterwards yeah playing with the media
with the beard and the glasses just
looking at them I didn't get question
sir I didn't I didn't get that Ryan but
I I got a chance to watch it from afar
um obviously yeah but uh he he's uh he's
a good guy like uh again over the years
like I said people have asked me that
question but like that that's no knock
at any of the other quarterbacks that I
played with and obviously like I said I
mean Steve Young Hall of Fame
quarterback but I only got I only got to
play three years with but just think if
when you look at
rice in his career and the numbers that
he amassed he didn't have a drop off at
at the quarterback position because he
went from Joe Montana Hall of Fame
quarterback to Steve Young Hall of Fame
quarterback so what would have happened
if you had that I mean look at I I I put
this in I guess I I put it in
perspective because you look at the
things that I did with the number of
quarterbacks again if you want to
compare the ones you know compare those
quarterbacks to the Hall of Fame
quarterbacks that Jerry played with it's
kind of like it's apples and oranges so
you think about what I did with the ones
that I played with um who's to say what
I mean I think everybody knows what
would have probably happened I probably
have maybe five I probably
say
maybe maybe three to 5,000 more yards
who knows so you think you would have
cracked 20 if you if you were with Joe
and so meaning exact number of Seasons
Cherry had with Joe and young would you
had more yards more I would be I would
have I would have definely definitely
threatened can you pull up Jerry Rice
stats against uh Terrell I'm I'm
actually curious now myself because you
know Jerry uh can you pull that up cuz
I'm right at like 16,000 I'm right yeah
you're 15934 and Jerry was what he's
like 20 20,000 holy he's at
22895 22895 touchdowns 197 that would
have been I mean you you only needed 44
more you 153 yeah receptions he had uh
500 more little less than 500 more but
so so it's interesting because the the
point guard in the NFL is the
quarterback right so if you got a good
point guard you're able to you know like
car Malone had the advantage of having
Stockton right right so what would have
happened if somebody else had 15 18
years of a Stockton as a point card
that's what you're saying is the story
true about uh the one story I remember
the JJ come out of UCLA was 95 yeah I
used to watch him at UCLA he me uh
there's a guy from USC receiver Johnny
Morton I think he went to the Lions if
I'm not mistaken right and he was
playing with Herman Moore and and
Mitchell so was it Scott Mitchell the
left-handed uh Scott MIT your
quarterback but is there a story where
you guys are climbing up this hill that
Jerry would run and you and JJ are
running up with them and you guys beat
him in the first mile or whatever it is
and all of a sudden he comes back he
says you know hey young guys or some
this is a story a myth I've heard what
really happened I've I've never run the
hill with Jerry you've never run the
hill with Jerry not with Jerry okay have
not but we've heard this story and you
you know the story's been told uh uh
with was it so you were not part of that
story with JJ Stokes running up no I was
not have you ever heard this story what
others telling it or I may have but uh
yeah I'm not familiar when they tell the
story have you heard it with your name
being included in it or no no I have not
you've not heard it so it's a story with
JJ being in this St it might have been
JJ but I I I wasn't uh yeah I I never
ran ran the how disciplined was his
training I guess that's the question I
want to ask very meticulous I mean I
mean even from his training the way he
uh put on his
uniform um just the way he went about uh
just being the receiver that he became
and he was um the difference with me and
Jerry Jerry he grew up as I guess as a
young kid wanting to be a football
player he wanted to be again a receiver
and then eventually and ultimately he
wanted to be the greatest receiver of
all time and he had a dad he had
somebody obviously to help him and push
him to to to be that I didn't grow up
wanting to be a professional football
player never thought I would would be in
a million years um I got to Chattanooga
on the heels of uh of another receiver
that they were recruiting in high school
and so I got there UT Chattanooga just
kind of like somewhat of on a package
deal and again I was very competitive um
I play I played number of sports in high
school I played uh baseball uh
basketball I ran track and and then like
I said uh getting to UT Chattanooga um
again I didn't really play much my
freshman year I didn't really play till
like late in the season um and then um
and then think my sophomore year is kind
of like was kind of like my breakout
year um my the coach that I had at the
time buddy Nicks um he didn't really
believe in playing freshman unless you
were like coming out as out of high
school unless you were like an
allamerican or you were a four five you
know four five star athlete and so I was
definitely not that coming out of high
school and so I just kind of just kept
working um just trying to find my way
and then my sophomore year I had
somewhat of a breakout Year my I think
late in the season I had um uh four
touchdowns against the defending
national champions Marshall thund
Thundering Herd at that time that was in
our conference um and I scored all four
touchdowns uh and we won the game 33 to
31 that was sort of like the stepping
stone of kind of like me you know
thrusting to uh you know on on the scene
of becoming a a receiver so you and you
sorry and you said you said that um so
your your mother and your grandmother
raised you to so how much of a role were
they were they more like okay like
you're a St like they could they knew
you were athletic but they were they
were they pushing you too was it you
just on your own in school cuz like you
were saying this guy had a father uh
your father your father wasn't in the
picture T so you had to find that on
your own and just realized yo I'm nasty
no I wasn't nasty in high school I was
just being being a kid just playing
sports um and that was just one of the
things and it was just kind of like one
thing after another I mean I had enough
skill uh I guess Talent like I said I
tried out for the basketball team I made
it you know what I mean um went out for
baseball I made it you know what I mean
um but I was never I wasn't I wasn't a
star you know what I mean obviously I
played football played JV and then uh
eventually my junior year I end up going
to Varsity um there are guys that were
like my freshman sophomore year they
were talented enough to play at the
varsity level and I saw those guys I
witnessed those guys I was never one of
those guys and so um when you look at
the the entirety of my career and how it
started and where I came from um for me
I still go back and I I'm like man how
did this happen um but I always talk
about you know um when I ultimately got
inducted into the all uh to the Hall of
Fame but prior to that I got nominated
in 2016 and I think about I'm like man
how did I get here and I always thought
about like how did this all happen and
then I just kind of reflected back on
everything and I had gone through uh who
had helped me along the way and then
just really just internally like there
was something about me that was
different than everybody else and so I
kind of just like man I sat back in my
in my condo uh after doing an interview
after uh being nominated in 2016 and I'm
like man how did I get here and I came
up with these 3DS which is desire
dedication and discipline I had the
desire to play whatever it may have been
but when you think about guys that are
considered
great you think about what it takes to
do that with every athlete there has to
be some sort of dedication but what
really separates the great from the good
is discipline and I was I was fortunate
enough and I'm I had enough wherewithal
to think about like how did I get here
when I start to think about and then
throughout the course of my career
people start saying man you're the
Michael Jordan of football what Michael
Jordan the
football who would have ever thought
that I never would have thought that me
and I and I say this because I'm like
what at what phase did they say that how
early this was I mean at when I was
pretty much at the height of my career I
guess it was like I guess year I early
on that's I guess year maybe six or
seven you know I mean going into eight
you know I mean with San Francisco and
then I went to Philly and then I was you
know my game was off on another level
and then I went to Dallas and it was
still on another level um it was the
consistency from like maybe four a year
four or five and it the trajectory of of
my my my skill set and my talent it was
still trending at at at at at a level
that I started to realized like man when
I stepped on the field I felt
Unstoppable um and all that came came
about because of really number one my
desire um to to play the sport and then
I I saw the greatness in the locker room
that that I was in with the Jerry Rices
you know the the Tim McDonald's the
meron Hanks U the Steve Youngs and then
I saw JJ Stokes like these guys helped
develop me into the receiver that I
became because I I came out when I came
out I was really raw and green uh I
wasn't really I wasn't playing at
Chattanooga I didn't play the power five
Scoops I didn't play the tough stiff
competition to where I was ready to play
as soon as I stepped on the field in San
Francisco when I was drafted in 96 I
didn't have that that that that that eye
pooing ability to play right away like a
Randy MTH coming in coming coming out of
college you know you saw that ability I
didn't play right away it took like
three to four years for me to really get
to where I got to and and and become the
receiver that I became um just by just
really working hard it was really due to
those 3DS the the desire the dedication
and the discipline when you think about
some of the greatest that to ever play
their sport from whether it's baseball
whether it's tennis you just think about
all the greats there's only a handful of
those guys but if you think about every
sport there's a lot of good athletes but
there only a handful of great ones and
discipline is what separates when you
listen at people talk about people that
they played with or coaches that have
coached great players or their peers
that have you know played against them
played with them it's always something
different and discipline is that word
that did you love the game did you love
the game I I came I I became in love
with the game because I I started to
become in love with the process in which
I became the receiver that I did I had a
I had a personal trainer that I that I
acquired in in 90 right after the 99
season after I after I caught the past
um uh to beat Green Bay um I'm sick sick
Brett fars look is that the one you're
saying afterwards highlight show his
face
dog yeah right um so I like I said I'm a
big basketball fan I'm living in Atlanta
at the time so I go to Crunch and
Buckhead and I'm all that that that was
my way of conditioning that was my way
of keeping myself in shape when you talk
about the heel that you know Jerry I
never really ran routs I never really
focused on Route running or anything to
like training camp I never did any on
the- field things I didn't do anything
to really I guess uh enhance my football
abilities as far as route running never
not not to year n
that was the first time I really worked
out um you're nine you're not with are
you still at San FR or you're I'm with
the I'm with the Philadelphia eag that's
right cuz you played eight with 49ers
right I only that and I say this because
and I'm and I and I'm I'm saying this
and because I think about now like you
see all the uh the Youtube and the
training and all these guys with these
personal trainers this that other they
running routes I'm like I wonder what my
career would have been been like if I
would have dedicated myself in the off
off season like these guys have and I
never did that until year nine is like
when I got uh traded to eventually get
getting traded to the Philadelphia
Eagles um Donovan had he was living in
Arizona and he wanted to try to get get
the guys on the on the field all
together try to get a feel for each
other to develop some chemistry um right
before the season and so that was the
first time I had really gone and ran
some routes uh taking some time to to to
devote to like okay I'm going to go run
some routes today and and and and do the
things like that but that was the first
time in in my career so so then to me if
I may here's you know like if you're in
high school if you're 66 in 10th Grade
and you don't like basketball guess
who's going to come knocking on your
door the coaches right they're going to
say hey Johnny come on yeah what do you
mean you're going to play ball I I don't
play basketball I play video games no no
you're going to play ball come on down
you know you're going to come we're
going to teach you how to play this game
and then a couple years later maybe you
do and then 5 years later you're in the
NBA and at that point you may be a
center at the Lakers called Andrew bam
you know and maybe you don't love the
game but you're great at the game Andrew
B was great at the game and I would
watch and I'm like I don't know if we're
even asking the most basic question does
this guy even love the game you know so
so for me when I watch you I'm like okay
so if you can pull up the picture of
Terrell Terrell Owens okay so this is
you men's fitness there's God knows how
many pictures of your physique absolute
human specimen uh is what you are and
sometimes like for the average person
they can work 5 days a work out 5 days a
week at the gym for five years and they
still may not look like that okay
there's certain things that genetics
plays a role uh when you're looking the
way that you're looking but if there's
no Love of the Game and the game kind of
just comes like I just shook your hands
right now can you put your hands right
here so just the audience can see still
got M look look at this I don't
think people realize like if you you see
Terrell Terrell's hands it's just
I felt like a baby going so but but
again Phil Jackson would call Jordan's
hands what do we call him mits mits he
says this guy had these hands right so
and you just answered a question where
you're kind of like the Love of the Game
came in ninth grade and not ninth grade
your ninth year in the NFL or make kind
of the process did you struggle with
that you're like look I'm just playing
this cuz I'm good at it this this is a
joke you guys are trying so hard I can
do this with my eyes closed did you kind
of have that mentality uh no I mean I I
I was umed uh early on in my career
because again like I I mentioned I was
really raw from a skill set standpoint I
had the physical attributes um when you
think about that that the the end of the
90s I I was drafted in 96 and when you
think about that era and you think about
the receivers that were that were
playing at that time they were tall like
six feet 63 6'4 uh you mentioned one of
earlier like the Herman mo mo the Herman
Moors uh Jake Reeds um JJ Stokes he was
66 like uh Chris Carter Michael Irving
uh J Rice these were this was the the
state of the game at the time these were
the big receivers so I had the physical
uh attributes that they were looking for
in a receiver at that time um but there
was a lot of things I didn't possess um
to again I was drafted off
potential um and then like I said I I
had the prototypical type of body that
were that was playing at in the league
at that time and then just remember that
was common as what you're saying yeah
exactly so uh everything that I've done
like I said there's there's some thought
behind it you know like I said just
follow me prototypical was I was what I
kept hearing coming out of uh College
like oh he has a prototypical body blah
blah blah blah the height you had the
physical attributes there were things
that I had to do along the way to
enhance my abilities as a receiver um
that's where my my personal trainer came
into play but once I started to figure
out the game itself um once I started to
figure out uh and put things together as
far as like you know I I was struggling
reading defenses because I played I
played at a division onea school I
didn't play like I said the powery
school I didn't play the competition um
when I got into training camp um it was
tough the bump and run I had I struggled
with that free access I could run free
access all day uh but once guys saw uh
saw in in training camp that I struggled
with bump and run every day we had
one-on ones though that that's where I
got better and then they started to like
you know come up and press me you know
um I can run routes off coverage all day
but once they saw that I struggled
that's was some that was something that
they wanted to do every day and then we
watched the film after practice I mean
everybody had oneon-one routes and so as
we went through the film you know coach
got frustrated with me because I
couldn't get off bump and run so it was
just like a almost like a wasted rep and
it got to a point it became repetitive
like we would we go to the film I knew I
was coming up like he would critique me
you know first the first you know couple
of times and after a point it was like
it was almost embarrassing because he
was just go to the next person because
he's like I'm tired of trying to you
know get you to you know learn this and
get out this blah blah blah blah so I
took it upon myself to kind of work
after practice we had a martial arts guy
named George Chung on our uh on our team
that was kind of just on the team that
that kind of just worked with players or
what have you why to get off a bumping
runs exactly so uh yeah so I mean he
just like AR like pushing off wow that's
great that's a good idea hand hand plat
things of that nature and then obviously
with hand you got to move your feet too
so there were some things that I had to
work on was like you know footwork hand
work and so when you think about you
know bump and run a DB what they want to
do is disrupt you you know coming off
the line of scrimmage Ag and so when you
think about we talked about earlier you
think about the West Coast offense which
I play for played in a number of systems
but most of my career I played in West
Coast kind of offenses or what have you
which is
predicated timing and precision so you
can't waste any time you know coming off
the line because the quarterback has his
progressions I mean I guess an average
play is what between three and four
seconds um so you got to you got to
think about okay if you're first in the
progression second or third or what have
you then you can't be Dilly ding at the
line of scrimmage you got to have a plan
a you got to have a plan B in a split
second plan C you're not going to
probably get to play see because the
quarterback's already Mo moved on to to
option two to option three depending on
obviously the matchups depending on the
coverage or what have you and so those
are some of the things that I had to
work on to enhance my abilities as a
receiver would you say you were
coachable very coachable my coaches I'm
tell Larry kiry my first year uh first
uh first few years in San Francisco
George CH uh George Stewart who was my
my first three years uh while kiry was
my receiver coach he was my special
teams coach so coming in as a rookie
you're not starting right playing right
away you're going to play special teams
so I played a lot of I played special
teams I played either you know on the
punt team uh I played on kickoff I
played kickoff return and so again
that's kind of like you know like the
groundhog days of being being being a
rookie like you got to pay dudes and so
that's what I did and so that's was why
that's how I became and like coaches saw
that I was tough um and then when George
steart who was the the special teams
coach he became my receiver coach when
he came in that room and he knew that I
was with the Jerry's the JJs and I was
It was kind like we were three-headed
Monsters Just Like You know the Vikings
had uh Chris Carter they had uh Randy
Moss and they had uh who they had
another receiver yeah they did they had
another receiver who was the guy that
they had they had a third option was was
re up there at that time no no they had
a third option I can't remember who it
was but they had a third option yeah but
it was like it yeah so got I got
interesting the Rams the Rams had that
too when had is Bruce Tory Holt coming
up and Ricky P on the slot right so they
had that comparison of us big three in
like uh in San Francisco versus uh the
the Minnesota Vikings uh big three and
so
those those guys kind of like said kind
of motivated me to to become who I
became because like I said there was a
lot of work to be done but if honestly
said if I didn't have my personal
trainer buddy P that I that I came
across with the you know from a guy that
I ran ran into that introduced him on
the basketball court I don't know
honestly where my career would would be
what I what I want to know so I got
obviously from a fans perspective we've
watched the controversy with you over
the years and we've watched what
everyone said whether it's maruchi skip
you Stephen A I've watched a lot of that
stuff over the years but I'm listening
to you right now and I'm wondering one
um okay so this guy's got an
unbelievable skill like you said
prototypical you know you know the what
was the word you use that they're
they're calling you when you're coming
out of college he's the the typical wide
receiver prototypical physique you know
you're 63 215 you look bigger but it it
used to say 63 215 and you're coming out
playing does he love the game does he
not love the game okay and you know if I
had you know the same amount of years I
played with Joe Montana and Steve Young
what kind of stats would I put up you
know what would I have done you
destroyed people I mean I've seen you
one time you know Dion's playing defense
on you you just push him and Dion Falls
and he's even laughing at himself the
way you threw him I me that even he
jokes about and you guys are friends
right but fast forward to today you know
uh look looking back with your game you
said a few things earlier you said you
know I was raised by my mom and my
grandma no father figure in the picture
let's just say you did have a father
figure what is the benefit of having a
father figure what is a you know a
difference between a fatherless home
versus a father raising uh terrot what
would have been the difference um I
probably have to say uh structure uh
kind of like you know having uh that
that that voice or having somebody to
lean on uh to talk to um I mean there's
there's there's responsibilities you
know with the mom in the in the in the
household and the dad in the household
um at certain at a certain age
especially from the time that you're
born you're you're you're dependent upon
your mother for a large part of that and
then at some point you transition you
know from being around the mom all the
time to where okay this is where the dad
has to pick up the pieces and this is
where especially if it's whether it's a
daughter or or or a boy or a son you
know what I mean and and and this is
where you have sometimes you have like
uh uh um you know girl dads boy dads and
so for me I never got a chance to to
experience that
because as I went through life I started
to look at other male figures as as as
as to how to go about life and how to do
certain things when I didn't have I
didn't have an uncle a big brother to to
lean on to talk about tough questions or
or go through tough times with um when
you think about a father I mean they're
very much needed in the household when
you need somebody to talk to and then
again there's guy things that Mom can't
do that's right you know what I mean and
vice versa yeah and so I just like I
said I I I don't know how different my
life would be um but who's to say but I
mean you can only imagine like I said
being in a structured household versus a
not structured household or or a two two
Family household in a single single
family household yeah there's three
things I'm I'm in Dallas a couple days
ago and I was talking to an audience uh
crowd with sapa's birthday I say every
boy needs three things he needs someone
to love someone to respect someone to
fear okay so you know in most cases love
is Mom if you got a dad you can love as
well even better but you don't
necessarily need it if you got both them
in the household right respect you want
to respect mom but maybe you know not at
the level you respect a man that's going
to check you right and then the fear so
the 14-year-old 15-year-old 16-year-old
Terell who did you fear my grand you
feared your grandma oh my she was no
joke really oh yeah she I always say
that she was she was kind of like my
mama and my dad um she raised me again
she raised all of us um and so again my
mom had me at an early age um and then
you know honestly you know her dreams
got you know was cut short because she
had kids and so she couldn't do the
things that that she wanted to do she
had aspirations to to be a model she had
aspirations to to to be a designer and
do those things and so it's so funny now
as I as I progressed throughout my
career and I saw and I got to know what
those things that she wanted to do I got
a chance to do those things she kind of
kind of got to live vicariously through
me and so my Grandmama she was she was
she was she was very strict she was a
disciplinarian to to to the to the m
degree um and I got a chance to
understand like too how she grew up and
she was she raised us how she grew up um
think about the the segregation era of
of of of having to to to
just face racism do all you know
experience those things and I didn't
know anything about it but I used to be
around when she used to be on the phone
and talk to certain people about about
how she grew up and how her mom and dad
grew up and just the whole black and
white picture I didn't understand at
that time but As I Grew Older I got a
chance to understand and look back I'm
like oh this is is what she meant um so
again when you think about racism you
think about systemic racism those are
some things like I said I heard but then
as I went through life and I got older I
got to experience a little those a
little bit of those things and so when
you think about how she was raised and
then how I was raised um honestly like I
said I mean she she replaced you know uh
the father that I didn't have but again
as I grew up and I went through life I
realized me not having a father and then
me having kids I didn't want to I didn't
want to be that to my kids I didn't I I
wanted to go a different path and then
sometimes it's all about like I said you
don't have to be in the same household
but you have to be present at some point
in time in your kids' lives and so for
me I have kids um and I always try to be
supportive and I try to be there be
there for them when I can relationship
now because you know as a kid my parents
got divorced and I was you know my I saw
my dad once every other week when they
got divorced when we came here I lived
in Germany 2 years at a refugee camp I
didn't see my dad there when you were
when you were uh uh later on yourself uh
I think you had a did you rekindle the
relationship with your there was a
meeting with you and your father right I
think O winfy Network where you guys had
a sat down yeah right aan VanZant did a
show had a show called Fix My Life And
so uh yeah they reached out to me about
doing it and uh it almost didn't happen
because he signed on for it and then you
know I think it it really got deep for
him U Got tough for him and he almost
backed out of it but he's he's stuck in
there and uh we we went through it and
that was the first time honestly on that
show that was the first time I had ever
seen my mom and my dad in the same room
for you know more than five minutes um
as I went through the city I grew up and
I saw him around town it was kind of
like more of high by you know what I
mean maybe spend a five five to 10
minutes here with him uh here and there
but that was pretty much the extent of
it but my dad lived right across the
street from me um living with my grandom
Grandmama um and so ultimately like I
said I found out that he was my dad but
at you know at some some point like I
said there was a time that I didn't know
and then once I found out like I said it
was just kind of like okay he's my dad
so you what age did you know the uh
around like 11 or 12 yeah somewhere in
there I was a pre-teen got it and are
you guys good now like do you have a
relationship or no it was just I mean
it's cordial I mean we don't have like
the best of any nothing changed nothing
really uh drastically changed when I
made it to the pros it wasn't like he he
knew that I was a professional I made
money it wasn't like you know now he
wanted to L uh leych on uh it was
nothing it was respect that either
sometimes you hear those stories that's
that's good to hear it right it was
nothing um you know close to that is
there an effort like is there like hey
you want to have you know lunch you want
to go to dinner once a quarter or
something like that when I go home I
make it a point to stop by and you know
my Grandmama she passed in 2012 um you
know my sister my nephew they live in
the house so I always go by and like I
said our town is so small I mean you
know I just usually like I said when I
go go home you know my Grandmama is is
is who raised me so I always go ride by
the house and so he's always there last
night I'm watching the documentary of uh
the Sha 2500 Years celebration in Iran
it's not anything that has to do with
this interview and zahedi who was the
ambassador to us representing Iran he
was dating Elizabeth Taylor he said
something very powerful on this
documentary he says two things destroy
man status and money when you first came
and you experienced money you made
almost 100 million I think NFL I don't
know the exact contract I think you made
be 80 million bucks give or take NFL's
brought money what was harder to handle
was it more status eyeballs Limelight
you can't go out girls are me you're
good-look guy good body you got Swagger
you know how to talk was that tougher to
handle as a young man or was it money
sudden money coming into your hands it's
tougher to
handle uh I I don't think neither was
hard to handle I mean I think I I took
the fame I took it all in stride um
again I again I didn't see myself as a
superstar and I wasn't a superstar right
away um again I was drafted off
potential and so that potential really
didn't get tapped into to after that my
I would say like after that that Green
Bay uh playoff game that was when I
think I started to develop some
confidence in myself that okay I could
play at the next level um anybody that
knows about that game it didn't start it
didn't start well by any means for me um
but it and I always said it's it's so
cliche it's not how you start it's how
you finish um I had a terrible start of
the game and so for me I put a lot of
pressure on myself because I was a like
now I'm starting to play this is year
three now I'm starting to really play
alongside Jerry Rice JJ Stokes Brent
Jones um Steve Young I mean I'm starting
to be a part of the offense and so I
wanted and I for three years I got a
chance to watch highlights of Jerry I
got this watch practices of Jerry I got
to watch playoff games of Jerry and how
he performed and I wanted to be that I
wanted to be somewhat like him I wanted
to be that star and I put so I think I
put so much pressure on myself to to
make a play every time that I touched
the ball that it it was
counterproductive like it was just
something that just went wrong I had a
fumble I dropped a touchdown I mean
there were passes that literally I
watched into my hand after a couple ones
couple couple passes dropped I went to
the sideline and my coaches like man
just watch you know my my teammate they
like man just watch it all the way into
your hand but this is my third year it's
not like I don't know how to catch but
this for me I'm thinking okay this is
the playoffs in order to get to the
Super Bowl you got to win in order for
all these things to happen you got to
play well and so I wasn't playing well
at that particular time and so I
literally like I said it was one play
like I remember the route and my coach
like yo just watch it all the way into
to your hand because they saw that I was
pressing I literally I watched the ball
all the way into my hands and I still
dropped it still dropped it but I had so
much confidence in myself and when
you're in the league you you hear people
and players say it's like you go to the
next play you can't dwell on what just
happened because if you're just going to
linger throughout the course of the game
and essentially that's exactly what I
did I had to keep I go to the next play
um and you think about Jared Rice was on
the field on that last play in which I
ultimately caught when you think about
basketball and it's a last second shot
you need a bucket you're usually going
to put the ball in the best players
hands on that at that particular play
obviously Steve Young touch touches the
ball they the quarterbacks touch the
ball 99.9% of the time obviously he's
one of the best players on the on the
team but in that particular time we
needed to get the ball into the end zone
we got Jerry Rice on the other side we
got JJ we got myself we got Brent Jones
they ran cover two pretty much the that
entire series The play before I caught
the touchdown they ran exact same
coverage uh Steve Young threw the ball
to right before that play he threw the
ball on a comeback to JJ Stokes that
almost got picked off yeah and on that
play I saw that I was wide open because
they played cover two and cover two
you're playing a slot the middle is wide
open you have the seam yeah I'm and I'm
yo and I can't came back and I'm like yo
I'm I'm wide open on it so we call the
play It's called all go the play before
that was called all go double comeback
in which it almost got picked off and
throwing to JJ he called the same play
we got to go to the we got to take shots
the two outside guys instead of them
running comeback they got to go to the
end zone so it's going to threaten those
two safeties they got to they got to
play one way or the other so I think
that they were probably thinking that
he's going to throw that ball like I was
alluding to when you talk about
basketball you're going to put the ball
in the best player's hands
at that time I'm playing bad I'm pretty
sure they probably not thinking that
they're going to throw me throw the ball
to me but as an offense and as a defense
you have to play to your principles all
I did was run I ran the same exact route
and I just bent I saw the scene the the
middle wide open I ran it and Steve
Young threw the ball literally where it
could only be caught um and I made the
play I I caught it I I watched it you it
was like slow motion but and I didn't
know he almost fell on that play until
obviously watching the highlights could
I true question about that play he
tripped on the center's second step
right hold up but ask you a question too
cuz I mean he almost Falls by the way
you catch it Tio that that hit right
there probably would have been a penalty
today are you hurt right here or you
just like oh my God no I and when
literally it gives me chills to to see
this cuz immediately I thought about my
grandma wow dude immediately immediately
because she always she always she I I
was raised in the church and she always
told me taught me to just have faith no
matter what and in this particular time
like I said I had to have faith in my
abilities that I could be able to do
what I again internally mentally that I
you know it it wasn't showing that I
could do but I just had to have the
faith that to keep going to know that I
can make this play and Steve I mean he
put the ball literally like where no one
else could catch it but me sick and soon
as he soon as he hit as soon as I caught
it and they hit me and I went to the
ground I said Thank You Jesus wow I said
Thank You Jesus and I and I and my
grandma I literally I was thinking about
my Grandmama at that time amazing well
we as fans thought your shoulders popped
cuz you got sandwiched you were like
okay this guy's injured right now but
but again going back you know you know
what's funny I want to go back to the
question but I do want to bring
something up here that your reaction
right now to that clip but my question
still not answered so I want to go back
to it I want to go back to this clip uh
uh August 29th where you said this is a
this is this is terrible advice
ex-cowboy wide receiver Terell Owens
chimes in on Michael irin's words of
wisdom to CD blam right if I go to the
story and you'll see where I'm going to
this uh uh article here uh what page is
it is it eight there you go okay terens
criticized cowys writers micro advice
ter he took issue with the idea that the
receiver should primary catch the ball
with their body stating every receiver
coach and head coach is cringing right
now listen to the notion for receivers
to catch your body in some cases yes but
this isn't this isn't bad advice this is
terrible advice Owens emphasizes
disagreement with Irvin's advice by
highlighting his own impressive career
statistics stating that I got more
touchdowns and combined in the two of
you guys I think you're talking to is it
you're talking to who Carter and kesan
is that who it was you were talking to
yeah I no irin and Irvin and Kean they
had 139 you had 150 but but you in let
me understand what you were trying to
say and see if I'm understanding
correctly when you're going through the
middle guys don't want to go up and and
get the ball cuz you're going to get hit
you're going to get popped you you want
to catch the ball here there's
possibilities of being injured you
didn't give a you get up there and
go get the ball is that kind of what you
were alluding to yeah I mean in certain
situations especially um depending on
where the Defenders are um and and
today's game and and even when I play
Defenders are really crafty and they
know the catching points and where the
ball is being thrown so they're going to
try to stick their hands in there to
disrupt and dislodge the the football so
what I was alluding to like in certain
certain instances as a receiver you have
to catch the ball with your hands
because if you allow it to get close to
your body especially with a Defender
behind you they're either going to hit
you and have it and dislodge it or
they're going to just put their hands
they're going to slap the ball down
versus catching the ball out front
versus letting the ball get here from
the I would never I it I would never let
a ball get to here if I'm running away
from a running away from a Defender why
would I why would I let the ball get to
here because with having a tenden
because if you have late hands anything
if you have your hands drop and you you
have late hands and you start the B you
see the ball coming to you and it hits
you're going to have a tendency to
probably drop that ball because it's
going to hit your pass and it's going to
Ricochet off it's going to bounce off
versus catching the ball with your hands
yeah and tucking it you've had a lot of
coaches which coach has ever told you to
catch it with the body not with the
hands has any coach ever told you never
I've never coaches you liked or disliked
never told you catch with the body no
I've never I that would be the dumbest
thing for Co and this is Michael iring
why would with your with your
body it's not to say that you can't but
there are Basics there are Basics
fundamentals to to everything and the
basic fundamental for catching a
football is to catch it with your hands
you're not going to tell a kid teach a
kid to catch it with your body even if
you're throwing with a little kid or
whatever you wanting that kid to catch
it with their hands right because if it
gets to their body what are they're
going to typically drop it and this is
Kean and Michael both of them had glues
they had great hands as well I mean you
know ke can't they caught a lot of balls
but then you think
about to be a receiver and to obviously
to be a a really productive receiver you
want to score
touchdowns and you look at those two
catch I think Michael was more of a body
catcher and he was talking from his
experience he's more of a body Catcher
And if you look at his game he catches
the ball a lot like this I I just never
I was never taught that way maybe he was
and maybe it worked for him um but for
me I just I just I don't understand like
I said being a professional uh that you
would encourage uh a body catch you
prompted three questions I got to get to
all of them I'm so curious let me go
back to it number one Limelight status
you went to the story and you talked
about how you caught the ball and they
went to you uh JJ almost interception
and you caught the game boom you didn't
answer the question so Limelight or
money for me I've experienced money and
you know where money to me didn't come
sudden because in the insurance game you
don't go from hey there's a superstar
insurance agent coming out of North
California boom next you get a $20
million it doesn't happen in Insurance
you kind of go from 100,000 to 200,000
to 400,000 and you oh I make a million I
make 10 million I made 100 million damn
we made $300 million it experiences that
way but in NFL you go from high school
back then College if you were getting
paid you were getting paid because you
were great you know valet guy you work
once a month and got a $100,000 tip but
for the most part people didn't get paid
back in the days in college right then
you come to the NFL then all of a sudden
you know as a fan Terell you're not a
fan of the NFL you're fan of a NBA you
said it earlier right as a guy that's a
fan of the game we typically as fans of
the game we follow two different things
okay when the leaders but when ESPN apps
comes out you're checking a couple
things one you're checking your team
right and two you're checking your
players but then there are some players
whether you like them or dislike them if
they're on you just got to watch them
right right you were one of those guys
so I became one of those guys you became
one of you were either a fan you were
either hated or you were on a team that
was winning so people were interested
and you didn't just play on any teams
that the fans are like regular fans
you're talking about 49ers hardcore fans
Eagles hardcore Cowboys religion you
didn't play on regular teams so going
back to it lmel I really want to know
because what what when was it when
you're like Shaq tells the story when
the first time he got money boom it went
like this right and I've had Shaq on and
we've talked multiple times boom money
went because he never seen money like
this before did the money or status were
you ever like I've never had this many
people and back then there was an
Instagram where you're getting 6,000 DMS
and you're like oh you never played
Instagram DM days right you're your
pre-at era right but there must have
been a time where you got certain
Limelight and money what did that do to
you uh it motivated me number one um as
far as the the Limelight the status
stuff I think
um I just took it all in stride I mean I
I I saw what super stars were like I got
a chance like I said as a rookie
watching Jerry um these guys are driving
Ferraris
Lamborghinis I was driving a Ford
Explorer The Limited Edition but it was
the top of the line but but it was the
limited edition yeah Ed that was a
limited all right love that car right
but that's what I was driving to
practice every day and I saw these other
guys they were driving Mercedes where it
was the coups or the sedans the
v12s that that's what motivated you
never had a Ferrari or Lambo nope you've
never had a Ferrari or Lambo no I wasn't
I wasn't even in I wasn't a Car Guy
what's the most expensive car you ever
had
uh Mercedes I think the V12 maybe or a G
wagon you had a you had you had a G
Wagon in San Francisco yeah yeah the
that that's it
nevering yeah but I mean that was what
motivated me and then
interesting I saw I I saw that
um I don't I don't think money changed
me um like I said again obviously
they're made a lot of money
um like I said what motivated me was
seeing what I could get based on what I
was doing on the football field and at
that point in time what I was doing on
the football field didn't warrant or
guarantee what I wanted so again a lot
of factors um helped me get helped me
along the way to become who I who I who
I became uh it wasn't like I said we all
have our motivations um but for me it
was uh my my training my per my training
my the way that I trained my body and
once I changed my diet my nutrition all
those things optimized my performance
and once I saw what those things did the
result of it I again I I I honestly I
came fixated I came I came obsessed with
the results and so that's why I trained
so hard in the offseason that's why I
took it I took things personally when I
saw my teammates not doing certain
things or I knew what I was doing during
the offseason and I'm like man obviously
these guys aren't working as hard as as
hard as I am because I knew I knew this
I saw the shoes that I eventually that I
had to feel in Jerry Rice um and then
the light the light bulb clicked on a
couple of times for me is when I when I
saw that the the ners traded Away Jerry
Rice and kind of just basically kind of
give me the keys to the car that was
like okay they think a lot of me to be
getting rid of getting rid of the
greatest receiver of all time who pretty
much has pretty much been a Mainstay for
that Organization for a number of years
and so for me to have this guy come out
of UT Chattanooga uh small division one
School uh small town in Alexander City
Alabama um and and see the potential um
of possibly again possibly taking this
franchise to possibly winning a Super
Bowl championship that's that's when it
kind of kind of all kind of all hit for
me so so so I do want you to ask the
question one thing I do want to know I
you still I'm still going to get into
the question I want to ask you okay
because I'm sensing The Language by the
way we got a ball here uh signed by
Terell Owens which some of you can get
and Rob you want to tell them how they
can compete for this ball here I sure at
the top of the chat there's a trivia
question something that Terell Terrell
had mentioned earlier sorry robt
something that ter had mentioned earlier
during the podcast uh if you click the
link it's in the top of the chat go
ahead and answer the trivia question and
one lucky winner is going to walk away
with that signed football as well as one
of the candles from 81 Loft I love it 81
home yes sir I love it let's put that
link below as well so let me go back to
it status I've listened to you and you
know I speak sign language and with sign
language is you know having been around
a lot of competitive people in our
industry we're very compe we have a
competitive environment you've talked
about yourself with Jerry multiple times
and uh uh
so I asked Kobe a question years ago and
Shaq wasn't happy about it he dm'd me
immediately and he blocked me eventually
we rekindled and our relationship is
fine today but when when I brought him
to our convention last year and his guy
says Hey Shaq wants to talk to you I go
to the back Shaq says you know that's
the dumbest question I've ever heard
anybody I said what was the question
that's a stupid question I I asked Shaq
the question how many championships
would he have had you know I asked Kobe
the question how many the late Kobe how
many championships would they have had
if Shaq would have had the same work
ethic as
Kobe and then you know Kobe gives his
answer we have 10 11 12 Rings right but
you you know everything is Jerry Rice
you know you know if I had Joe Montana
and I had Steve Young I would had three
5,000 more yards I would had 50 more
touchdowns and okay it's a great
argument that could have been made and
then running out of the two choices they
had they threw to me and you know
instead of going to Jerry I'm the one
that caught the ball we won we beat
Green Bay boom and earlier JJ
interception then you know uh um I asked
about the hill I would have thought for
sure you trained with him with the hill
you said you never went up to 2 and a
half mile hill with him okay I got that
and then also there was a couple other
comments you made about Jerry uh with
him you gave him respect but the the
language I'm getting from what you're
saying is you feel you were a much
better receiver than Jerry Rice is that
a fair question I had the potential to
be to to to be that the St statistics
doesn't say that but but longevity wise
like I said that's where it stands and
I'm always going to give him respect in
that regard but there's a lot of people
that watch our game and you kind of look
at how he played the game and how I
played the game a lot of people could
probably say that yeah I would have been
better than Jerry um but obviously like
I
said based on
my my genetic
makeup I feel like I could have eclipsed
a lot of things had I been able afforded
the opportunity to play three or four
more years I would have threatened a lot
of his records and it would have been
really it would it been it would have
been a no-brainer uh it would have been
very distinctive as who is the best
receiver of all time obviously does that
you know does championships come into
play depends on who you talk to because
there's a lot of great athletes that
don't have championships um that doesn't
mean that they're not Champions I mean I
I always say like yeah I don't have a
Championship uh Super Bowl champion uh
championship ring but I Played Like A
Champion um and so for me um I don't
need the championship to validate what I
did on the football field I think the
statistic your Optics if you watch How I
play the game it speaks for itself um
there's a lot of things that Jerry did
that I couldn't do early on in my career
um but there's a lot of things I caught
up very very in a short period of time
um when you think about the speed of the
speed in which we we play I'm F I'm I
became faster than Jerry um some of the
things that I I I struggled with um in
early on in my career was drop balls
when you look at the history of Jerry he
struggled with drop balls too at some
point in time um so Jerry set the
barometer he set the bar for everybody I
think a lot of receivers that that that
are playing the game today and I think
some people some kids will probably say
I've set the bar and for for how they
played and I've I've run across a number
of people that are either you know
athletes or uh moms or dads of of their
of their sons that have had basically
have said like yo you're the blueprint
um or for for for my son or for my kid
and they were always asking me like
advice as to how I became as good as I
did and it wasn't an overnight process a
lot of people don't even remember my
college career they just know of my
professional career because I didn't
play at a p school and obviously now we
in a in an age in an era of social
social media but again a lot of people
when I do interviews or I've done
speaking engagement some people they
don't even know unless I given the the
introduction they don't even know where
I played in college they just know about
me playing in San Francisco they
remember me going to the start they
remember the highlights on ESPN um the
the dances the touchdowns they remember
me playing in Philadelphia uh going
there you know um you know playing
lights out um going to the Super Bowl um
playing playing basically on a broken
leg in the super Super Bowl um they
remember me going to you know playing in
Dallas um playing against the Rivalry
teams uh playing against you know the
the NFC East whether it's the Giants or
the eagles they remember that they don't
a lot of people don't that they' be hard
pressed to find a lot of highlights and
a lot of clips from my my college career
let me let me go let me go back to this
on what you're saying with Jerry so uh
uh in your mind you said you're an NBA
guy right you said you're not an NFL
you're a fan of NBA I'm assuming you've
watched the last dance and I'm assuming
you you you know the stats and all that
you know the arguments the arguments
Michael versus LeBron Michael Kobe you
know and then boom you know well
Michael's got six out of six never went
to game seven LeBron Michael Kobe LeBron
that's my that's my order Michael LeBron
Kobe no Michael Kobe LeBron oh you have
Kobe head of LeBron okay in your mind in
your mind do you do you kind of tell
yourself you know I didn't have the
longevity that like do you look at Jerry
as Kareem and yourself as
Michael
yeah I could say that I that's what I'm
hearing from what you're saying I I I
could say that yeah sure I could say
that yeah um so you think you're MJ as a
receiver I I do I mean I did I played at
a I played at a level that not many
could play at considering where I came
from um I think like I said when you
think about you talk about those stats
had I played right away my first three
years if I had the ability to play right
away then you factoring I got probably
like maybe
at least 2,000 yard there in those first
three years but I didn't really play a
lot my first three years so you put two
there two there let's just say it's 2100
we give you that puts you at n uh 18,000
and then you kind of get a couple on the
back end maybe you'll be at 20 you know
in the goat conversation I don't know if
it's just stats because if you do stats
Malone will be in the conversation you
would have to put all these other guys
in the conversation Kim in the
conversation game so what do you what do
you put yourself against uh uh uh I
don't know uh not U I don't want to put
Calvin Johnson what do you put yourself
against Randy Moss you and Randy I feel
like I'm better than Randy Moss you
think you're better than Randy yeah
because of how I played the game I
played every facet of the game I didn't
just play receiver Randy played when he
wanted to and he said that and I'm not
he said yeah you know what I mean when
you look at when we when we my Coach
George Stewart like I I owe a lot of
what I became to my my coaches at every
stop pretty much Larry kiry George
Stewart and when I went to Philadelphia
Eagles uh it was David Cully and when I
went to Dallas it was Ray Sherman those
were when you talked about father
figures those were my father figures at
at my stops and those guys pushed me and
elevated my game to where it did because
they saw the potential that I had and
they didn't want me to they didn't want
they didn't want me to take it for
granted and so when you think about so
we there were like I said we played the
Minnesota Vikings um and there were
times that we played teams that played
the Vikings and coach would pull up
highlights of
Randy he would not even move it would be
a running it would be a running play
obviously it could be backside or
whatever the case he wouldn't even come
out of his
stance for me that's that's not a team
player um you think about guys that that
block down the field doing the extra
things not only when you have the ball
but when you don't have the ball that's
part of being a team player I played
every level of the game you know all
facets of the game I blocked I caught
the ball I caught the ball over the
middle um that was something I wasn't
afraid to do I mean it it comes with a
little fear you got to be kind of little
nuts but again but if you trust again
that's why practice com in into play
when you trust the guys when you trust
the practice habits you trust those
things that you're doing and you trust
that a
a quarterback is not going to hang you
out to dry but but if you're doing and
you're and you're where you're supposed
to be on a given route then you're not
going to have those hits you're not
going to have those bone crushing jaring
hits because you know that you've
prepared and you know what to do and
when to do it and if you're reading uh
if you're you you're becoming a student
of the game you're running your routes
and you're learning you know where the
holes are what when to run man when you
run Zone when you find a different holes
uh in the in the in the offense or in
the defense um there's something we call
the scramble drill when the quarterback
gets out of the pocket you have to be in
relationship to the quarterback in order
to get that ball and extend plays
obviously you got to have a quarterback
that can actually do it but for me I
mean I'm I'm big on acronyms um I was
going to say one earlier when you start
mentioning um you said the 3DS desire
discipline right and there was one yeah
you was going to we you were talking
about by Andrew bham you know we're
talking about uh B yeah I I got a
acronym for guys that that really
they're in the league but they don't
they're not really taking advantage of
their height and what they could could
be doing because they're they're in the
league because of height not sometimes
not because of a lot of skill and I and
I always tell that some of those guys
like they're BNR that's an acronym for
big for no
reason big for no reason I'm like bro
you can play better than what you are
you're just on the court because of your
height a little bit of skill but you
could be playing way better than that so
my other acronym is I call M ya which is
make yourself available and when you're
in that scramble drill um a lot of my
plays came uh big plays came off of that
because you have to be in relationship
depending on where you on the field you
have to be in relationship with the
quarterback and so when a quarterback
gets out of the pocket number one he's
trying to find you know the play is
broken down and he's trying to find you
know somebody to throw the ball to and
when when they're getting out of the
pocket especially when you have some you
know defensive guys that that can can
can really hurt you you know you don't
want to take you know you don't want to
be on on the other end of a of a Shawn
Maran hit or Ray Lewis hit or any of
those big guys so you're trying to find
they're trying to find you know the
first available non opposing team jersey
that they can to get the ball to so for
me depending on where you are on the
field you want to make yourself
available for that quarterback to get
the ball and then make some positive
yards and if depending like I said where
you're on the field you either you can
divert with that route go down the field
you can come across or you can come back
to the quarterback who was greater who
was greater Joe Montana or Jerry Rice
Joe Montana or o that I would I would
probably say Joe Montana so then that
says a lot so if you have a pick and you
got two players in the draft ahead that
you can pick up you got Joe and Jerry do
you pick up Joe or Jerry you're saying
Joe yeah Joe or Steve no no no no it's
Joe and Jerry Joe or Jerry there's a
reason why I'm asking this question say
you're under I'm going to go with I'm
going to go with Joe why is that why Joe
over Jerry Joe Montana over because Joe
I mean he just think about his his
Acumen of a quarterback when you think
about precision and timing and what I
watched and what I learned about the
West Coast
offense Joe is accurate he can get out
of pocket when need to he's he wasn't as
mobile as a Steve Young but he reminds
me and I think
of a Tom Brady he knows when and where
to put the ball it's ball placement his
timing he's going to put the ball where
it needs to be and he's going to create
in the offensive plays and the offensive
coordinat they're going to create
different matchups in order for you to
get the ball so for me to be on the
receiving end or be on the F on on the
field with the Joe Montana I know that
the the level of success that I'm going
to have with a guy like that that knows
where to put the ball when to throw it
and knowing me as a receiver what I can
do once I get my hands Joe or young I
Joe still Joe Joe mon yeah Joe Montana
Tom you know you know do you know why
I'm asking this question I'm asking this
question
because if if in your as a receiver if
you believe you're a better receiver you
know you running with Joe you think you
would have had better numbers than Jerry
running with Joe for the same amount of
years oh yeah okay that's where I was
going with it oh yeah because I think if
you you look at the how I played the I
mean I was a bigger um I was a able to
break a lot of a lot of tackles um
obviously going I mean like said I
didn't have to really go up and High
Point a lot of balls I didn't have to
early on in my career you didn't really
see me catch a lot of deep balls until I
left and I went to San uh Philly and
then and then Dallas and that was mainly
because of the quarterback
position so Garcia wouldn't throw deep
you have 54 touchdowns with them but it
wasn't a lot it was more runs catch and
run right Garcia we never if you think
about it you watch the highlights we
never was on a like the just say backed
up in our own territory and he wasn't a
guy that's going to throw you a 50 60 70
yard ball we never really got to throw
deep balls unless we got close to the
50 to where then okay we can take some
shots because he didn't have that strong
of arm our offense was predicated on his
skill set and he was better coming roll
out um not really a he was not not your
traditional pocket passer for for
instance uh uh interesting to be
thinking about that that that whole
process for me with Michael Tom I think
you wanted to ask something you were you
were looking at your notes to ask
something you bring up something really
really good about about being the entire
player right because there are receivers
who would block that no that no um
safety or Corner wanted to take their
eye off on the Block and I think of
Shannon sharp and Vernon Davis
MH big boys that were unafraid to block
and so somebody's in the slot and
they're coming across this way and all
of a sudden the cornerback disappears
where'd he go right well he wasn't
paying attention and you kind of played
Hines Ward used to did that too now hin
Ward also had a reputation for sometimes
being a little a little dirty maybe
little little late a little little later
than he was supposed to be right but you
had you had all that and you also played
at that time you say you don't really
talk about the eras but there are three
eras there is the era that Jerry drafted
in by the way it's a Niners and another
small school guy Mississippi State yeah
there a lot of similari there and you
had a time when he started guys like
Kenny Easley could do stuff that they
would get flagged all day for today then
you had the middle era right where they
changed the pi Rule and then you have
today's era it says you came right into
that middle era right and even though
you say I get together friends I don't
really watch the game is you know do you
think if you had back it up 7 years and
you had played in that much more
physical
era where do you think where do you
think you would have been in that
because it seems like your career is
like a pot of chili it just kept getting
better it kept cooking and getting
better you get draft you had the big
game in the championship you beat
Marshall hey this guy should be at the
combine picked in a third round mhm and
and obviously from your words here
you're saying you knew you could play in
the NFL but you weren't sure you were
going to stay in the NFL right it was
you you caught that ball when you think
back of that super physical era there
with with the physical attributes you
had when you think about your yards do
you think about today with the pi rules
are you thinking about that
era cuz it's different today it's easier
to get yards today than it was 10 years
ago or 20 years ago yeah that's why I
say there's such there's an inflation
with these receivers with their yards
now because they really can't get
touched and then a lot of defensive
guys they're not they're not hitting
guys they're which could lead obviously
to interceptions
incompletions they're not really playing
with the physicality um that you
mentioned that that early on they're not
playing with that type of physicality um
so what's your question to me is like
would I which era would I would have
yeah if you look to when Jer started and
you're comparing yourself to Jerry's
yard you have to remember when he
started right there's a famous quote
from Joe Montana He said there's one man
that I want to know where he is at all
times on the field and it's not on my
team it's Kenny Easley he said that it's
like five years into his career because
of the era so when you compare yourself
to Jerry I'm asking you to go back and
think about that era that Jerry started
in where you had to be so crafty and so
aware cuz the pi rule was different and
you know who I'm talking about right and
so again that that's that's where I I I
I alluded to earlier when when you think
about going across the middle um there's
a lot of ways to protect yourself you
can't just be running aimlessly just
running routes just because okay you got
a dig route and it says go over the
middle at 15 yards there's a reason why
you have to go a certain down a certain
distance there's a reason why you have
to you know check up in the hole there's
a reason why you have to keep on the
Move um that's where practice comes into
play um and there are Tendencies again
like you said there's some guys on the
other side of the ball that can play
just as well uh as as the guys on the
offensive side there's a lot of guy
defensive guys that play they're just as
smart so again that the quarterback
again they can protect you with throws
and again you have to know where guys
are that can disrupt the game um but I
think if I played in Jerry's era um
again I think I would have been just as
successful especially with a quarterback
that is that is very Cal like a Joe
Montana and then a Steve Young because
like I said Everything Is that West
Coast offense is predicated on precision
and timing and there wasn't back then to
your point there wasn't a lot of these
exotic defenses that defensive
coordinators and schemes are playing now
and the athletes are not as
great then as they are now
either so so okay let's transition did
that help with your question Tom I don't
know if you were trying to give him
question or you want to know how much
you know the game we all know you know
football very very well knows the
history comparing I wanted to go back to
the real era and even even even on that
catch against Green Bay they would have
called those guys for penalties for
hitting them the way saw guy get a flag
the other day I didn't even understand
I'm like what was the flag for this for
hurting his feelings the guy hit
somebody hard and they gave they gave a
flag made no sense to me look at how
they baby babysit the quarterbacks I
mean oh forget you can't even touch them
do this yeah like that's crazy you're
going full speed and then you run into a
guy's leg and you're calling a flag like
you can't Freeze Frame uh your speed and
then move yourself out of the way not to
hit somebody they even moov the the
kickoff right like T you don't even see
any kickoff or turns I mean that's
that's one of the most exciting parts of
the game that's gone yeah so so let's go
with with uh uh uh let me see if I've
covered this I've cover this I got this
this this I got all of this good uh
Stephen A and Max Kellerman uh these
guys had a show prior to that it used to
be with what skip Alis and Skip and
Stephen used to do first take and a Max
comes in and I think Skip goes with uh
Shannon sharp uh and by the way Shannon
one of my favorite speeches Hall of Fame
Shannon gave it one he said he believes
his brother needs to be in I don't know
if you remember that speech he gave
saying Sterling sharp needs to be in a
Hall of Fame as well right Sterling was
in tears but Stephen A and and you and
Skip where did all these issues start
did the issues start with you being on
and saying you know Max is blacker than
you are Stephen A cuz you tweeted out
the other day like a month ago you put
it out and Steph a had to respond to it
where did the issue with you and Stephen
A
start uh I think it started with that
comment um that I that I mentioned about
you know Max being you know blacker than
Steve or seeming to be black you know
kind understanding more black topics and
at that time we were talking about the
Colin Kaepernick situation um when he
was trying to get back in the league and
so he was just it was it was just so
against what Colin Kaepernick was was
doing and so again at that point in time
uh I don't know how the flow of the
conversation went but Max was making
more sense with the commentary um
towards that topic and that's where I
was I said it tongue and- cheek because
if you watch the clip I was laughing and
I didn't really think much I didn't
think too much of it and obviously he
took offense to it and then obviously it
resurfaced uh like you said about a
month ago and all I did was it was
something he mentioned on Joe bu's uh he
was talking about uh why Max he was part
of the reason why Max is not on the show
he didn't like him he said he was he
wrote it in his book by the way he he
broke it on B about him being Oceans
Apart because he wasn't an athlete and
he I guess I didn't he didn't go to
school to be a journalist or what have
you but that doesn't discount a guy's
knowledge for anything information or
whatever the topic may be and so I just
basically and like said I didn't bring
up I didn't put up the clip some the
other fans saw the you retweeted it
right some the fans saw the podcast and
they reacted to his comments and so I
didn't know what happened I just kept
getting alerts and I was being tagged
and so I just saw it and I'm like facts
that's all I said and so obviously he
took offense to it and uh yeah we went
went got into a little little war of
words right there what did he asked the
question on his rebuttal to you he says
what does it mean to be blacker what
what does that
mean what does it mean well it was the
topic in which they were discussing like
I said me being like I said being a
black being a black American like I said
me understanding how we talk in in the
streets and as it relates to whatever
talk uh whatever topic it seemed that
Max would have been more keen on the
culture than he was as far as his I
guess his responses to uh whatever
topics that we were we were talking
about at that time and that that was
what that was if I'm not mistaken that
was uh when you know Kaepernick didn't
want to show up unless of the contract
or the agreement because what Stephen A
was saying the fact that you would have
shown up anytime any place and you
probably would have shown up without a
contract you would have just showed up
to see how you know whether you you you
know the teams want to see because you
were confident like anytime any place
I'll come run routes with anybody right
but there was something along there was
something added or or or taken out of
the contract that he had to signed it's
not standard it wasn't standard uh for
whatever he had to signed and so for
whatever reason his men Colin speaking
uh his management Colin management team
they saw something wrong or saw
something kind of fishy with that and
they again they changed their mind at
the last minute and went somewhere else
that doesn't mean that yeah again he
can't play or he can't be evaluated the
same if there was something fishy about
it then yeah I probably would have taken
a different route as well it doesn't
matter football fields they're all the
same size no matter where you go you
think you think with Kaepernick uh you
think the NFL was more uh against him
playing or you think Kaepernick Was His
Own Worst Enemy because there's two
arguments right there's these arguments
where you know uh uh guys will sit there
and they'll say you know uh dude if you
really want it don't sign any contract
just come and watch me okay I'm not
signing nothing just come watch me play
okay forget about the contract I'm going
to be there here's where I'm going to be
bring your guys watch what I got okay
stop acting like a victim all the time
and you know Kaepernick recently uh I
think came out whether it's in a
documentary or a book talking about that
you know my my the the family that
adopted me you know they injected
certain thoughts and all this other
stuff and you know some communities are
like dude they at least gave you yeah
here's call C on CNN calls out adopted
parents racism as he promotes new
graphic novel he was telling I mean his
white the the the white adopted parents
were white that adopted him but the the
week that people were questioning the
timing cu the week that this book was
coming out he was like oh by the way my
parents were racist the white parents
showed me racism in the house so for guy
that's that that's played in the league
a long time um uh one of the best to
ever do some called maybe the best to
ever do it as a receiver do you think
it's more the NFL you know trying to
hurt Kaepernick or you think cernick is
being a victim and getting in his own
way I mean it could be a little bit of
both um but I think it's like okay
obviously there was a a settlement
reached um with the suit so obviously
there's something there um but I think
I've heard it you know I've heard some
people say it too it's like okay you've
sued the the the the company that you're
actually now trying to go back and play
for yeah it's kind of weird it's it's a
weird kind of dynamic right um so I
don't know if that is factoring a
playing a part as to why they're not
allowing him to play but but you gotta
you got to understand like you can't you
can't sit up here and say that the guy
can't
play and and I I'm not you look at the
the I guess the quality of quarterbacks
that are in the league now that are
playing um you know for for instance
like Zach Wilson I mean he was drafted
number two pick what a few years
ago clearly you got to think that
somebody could go in there and play
better than Zack Wilson and I like I I
actually watched the game last night
because I've been rooting for the guy
because I'm like man he has he's shown
signs of what he could be as to why he
was drafted he was a second pick a
couple of years ago and so obviously
it's unfortunate for for Aaron but again
I'm like okay now this guy's been thrust
back on the scene I think for me it's
like God's giv you another opport like
can you can you seize this moment um
again like I said whatever doubts or
mental struggles he's had over the first
two years okay
now okay you bring in Aaron okay you're
kind of been humbled a little bit okay
now you need to kind of really
prioritize what you need to do to get
better because clearly this organization
has taken uh vested into you for for the
pick in which they chose you and so now
he's back on the scene and obviously
like I said I'm like I said I've been
rooting for the guy to like really just
come out of the Funk and Reed play like
he's capable of playing I think when you
saw him play against the the Kansas City
Chiefs you if you if you just if you
didn't know who Zack Wilson was and you
knew that Aaron roders were supposed to
be playing this year and you looked at
those passes if you just saw a clip and
you looked at those passes you would
have thought Aaron Rogers was throwing
those passes he's a stud well though he
was a stud in that game is what he's
trying to say he's not saying he was I
was at the game we were at the game in
in New York right we went to watch him
play against the Patriots couple weeks
ago went to the
Yankees yeah went to the you forgot
already yeah so so we watch him play and
and and I feel what you're saying he
show signs but you're saying Kaepernick
is better than Zack I'm I'm saying he
can he can play J if he can't play worse
than Zach i i i i bro you can't I can
play right now given the opportunity and
I'm not just saying that just to be
saying it bro I'm telling you I can play
people watch me train yeah training work
like I can go out and play right now if
I could if I was given the opportunity
to to play 60 70 steps no understanding
who I am and what I where I am at at age
third down Red Zone that's where I would
be a viable asset to a to a team but
we're talking Colin Kaepernick right now
you're trying to tell me his skill set
and what he's done and what who cares
you can bring up stats as to what his
record was when he last played there are
guys that are playing now you can be
equally the same or worse but I know I
feel like he has the ability to to play
but again to your points like is he
stepping in his own way I have no idea
um only the ones that that the poers to
be can answer that it's cap a friend of
yours like do you guys talk regularly no
I've reached out to ceret a couple time
I've seen cap a couple of times here and
there so it's not like you guys are
friends and relationship buddy buddy
dinner all the time yeah yeah I'm not
yeah I I don't have a dog in to fight I
got you okay yeah I've reached out to
him even when he was on this trail of
trying to working out with guys I was I
had reached out and even know some
people that know they get back to you no
you and cap have never communicated no
wait a minute never not once no that's a
very interesting because you know if
somebody would have watched that with
you and and uh and uh Stephen A and Max
they would have thought like you guys
talked to Colin right before and you're
his boy and you're defending him and all
this stff this is very weird to hear
this now I'm just under I just
understand the Dynamics of what's going
on and I understand like you said when
you talk about the contract that they
signed like there's certain language
then they went in there to amend certain
things here if he's not getting back to
you okay to you you're you're you're not
no but but I'm you're not even in it all
I'm saying is from an outsider I'm not
involved so you don't even need to
comment on this I'm just giving you mind
all I'm saying is from an outsider
here's Hall of Fame you know
receiver that is defending you and you
don't want to even you know give him
that tells me more about his character
if you ask me and you don't even say I'm
telling you those are my words that I'm
saying this but going back to Stephen A
I like Stephen A okay there's there's
some people that don't like Stephen A
and there's a lot of those and there's
some that like him what's your what's
your biggest challenge with Stephen A or
if any if you don't if you say I don't
have any challenges with them what's
your biggest challenge with him I don't
know if there's a challenge but I think
it's consensus like for people that have
had I guess uh an experience or
encounters with him that watch him um I
think they've seen a kind of shift and
change in in in his his delivery
or I guess his objective takes against
certain athletes versus other athletes
um and I'm pretty sure uh he'll try to
really differentiate you know why he
says certain things about certain guys
and or not or he could say he talks
about everybody the same um but when it
when it comes to certain athletes I
think you know it's it's a different
tone it's a different energy um and for
me um you know we came across each other
I guess some some years ago um he's
talked very highly of me um he's
defended you on many occasion before um
and then like I said I just didn't like
uh I I didn't like the way it came
across when he had his obviously his his
podcast obviously millions of viewers
and he was holding up he was holding up
you know paper like he had documents on
me like like he had something on me and
I'm like and and you do that you're like
oh well I've talked to this guy they
told me not to do it this that but I
have a lot of stuff on you and I'm like
like you would think that like he has
something on me what is it that you have
on me that you you can't reveal or like
and I encouraged him like whatever it is
I'm like if it's not in the courthouse
or in a in in a in a in a in a uh police
precinct then I'm good what you had like
you had classified documents against me
I guess with something that I've done
wrong and so that he was going to like
he said he was going to Expos me that
was his word he was going to expose me
expose me for what like I'm a very open
and honest guy I'm an open book you know
um so I'm like I tell even with my
dating like I'm an open book some I just
I'm hard to read you know what I mean so
with that you know I just I didn't like
that about it that he felt like and it
made it it insinuated that he had
something on me that he was going to
expose something about me that I guess
the public didn't know um like I said
whatever the case may be and then he
insinuated that it was you you know what
um there was a a money grab situation um
involved in this because of uh the suit
that my attorney had filed against ESPN
with something that happened on the air
and so he was mad and upset about that
so that's where it all uh kind of
resurfaced or rekindled with that
interview uh with Joe Buon and then when
I responded with the retweet when I said
facts the read I get with Stephen A the
following readed I've spent a little bit
of time with him when when I was in
Connecticut we did one interview
together that's the only interaction
we've had and I've just watched him
again I've watched you guys more than
you've watched us cuz you we we're we're
not playing you're playing so we watch
your game and I get the feeling from
Stephen a uh that he's a guy that is
very proud to be africanamerican black
am he's very proud that means a lot to
him because that's his family's Legacy
that's the feeling I get from him but
also at the same time the feeling I get
from him deep down inside is the fact
that there's an element of a bit of him
being conc conservative because he was
raised conservative and he's got an
element of that and sometimes you know
bringing those political side of mindset
that he has in it gets him in trouble
because he can't please everybody and
he's a tough place to be this is why I
think he started his podcast so he can
fre freely talk to other people but you
know exact I like that I actually like
that I like the fact that he's doing
that I like the fact that he's going out
there talking to certain people that's
going to piss off the community and say
wait a minute are you black or are you
not you know are you doing this or are
you not doing that but uh uh
I can I can see both sides but now that
I'm hearing that you're you've never had
a conversation with Kaepernick get
you're defending him and he's never
gotten back to you a as as somebody that
played for the same team that he played
for and you played there for years and
yeah the history all of that it's a
little bit confusing to me yeah I even
reached out I know some people that were
working for him or know could have
gotten in touch with him directly got in
contact with him and I've had them reach
out to him and and and nothing yeah but
I mean it is what it is I can't I can't
I'm not going to force myself my force
my friendship on anybody but by the way
you know what this does do you know what
this does do this validates Stephen A
Smith's point it validates Stephen A
Smith's point on who Kaepernick is
that's what it does to me yeah I didn't
know you were going to say that but what
you just said about him validates who
Kaepernick really is that even the guys
listen in your life that if you have
people that even want to help you and
these are guys that are defending you
and it's not just anyway heavyweight
saying this it just validates Stephen a
maybe what he was trying to say were
trying to say and no because and going
back to the Colin Kaepernick thing it's
like I don't understand how I mean his
the off the- field actions your comments
obviously play a role too when it comes
to like the NFL he compared the NFL
combine to modern day slavery which and
as you know T if you get invited to the
combine white black Hispanic everybody
that's a that's a that's an honor you
know what I mean to go up there and
shine so he calls that and then it's
kind of hypocritical Aaron Rogers goes
down now you're calling that same league
to be like yo I want to play with you
guys they're obviously not going to have
a good uh a taste in their mouth you
know I mean like you just called us like
you know slave owners basically so then
he accuses his his white parents of
being racist so I have a question he
he's capitalized big time the race thing
with Kaepernick is huge he's made money
with Nike 40 million from Nike or
something like Nike Disney and then the
Netflix documentary Pat was insane if
you actually seen it so I just want to
know like for when you guys see somebody
like that t do you think that's a
genuine cause that he's he's doing or is
it basically he's doing it for like a
money because that he he took the cuz
the victimhood mentality there's money
in that bro so like do do you think that
that played a big role in it because I
mean athleticism aside he's making what
he made at least $40 million I don't
know what they can you pull up what the
go ahead yeah I uh yeah I don't I don't
know um obviously yeah um Nike is
obviously paying him big time um the
documentary uh speaking of I'm getting
ready to do a documentary that will be
sometime probably release some around uh
the start of the football season next
year dop I'll be doing it with uh Amazon
awesome what's it about uh just a little
bit of everything you know um your life
but it's your story I got you my life
yeah I mean but again it's not going to
be some fluff Story I mean I'm going to
you know it's going to depict and and
show like my imperfections uh some of
what we talked about what I went through
uh there are some stuff that I haven't
talked about you know relationship with
coaches um kind of how I was treated you
know by certain coach
uh Mar Uchi for one um you know my time
there in San Francisco the transitioning
you know from you know obviously Steve
Young to Garcia um how I was treated you
know you know myself with you know
compared to Garcia and and when my
contract you know negotiations were were
going on and how he was treated all
those things and so again I I got a
number of coaches that again that were
they wanted to be a part of uh this
documentary and I think a lot lot now
how has changed when you think about
the freedom in which athletes are are
are talking especially with podcast you
know just think if if I would have had
some of these platforms I would have
been able to dispel or dispute some of
the things that were being said about me
and how the media portrayed me uh namely
like I said obviously ESPN was the main
State like you know just with some of
the you know even guys that transition
from the field uh you know to to to to
on to to the desk and how I was being
characterized versus other players um
those are some of the things that that
that will be be revealed sick so and T
you mentioned uh systemic racism earlier
you spoke in the past of your
relationship with uh with Steve maruchi
you said uh in regards to him and I'm
going to quote it it was there talking
about systemic racism but you didn't let
it bother you didn't didn't let it
distract you from what you had to do on
the field but you experienced it during
and him and under him you're like trust
me I've experienced it like can you give
any example of like what you actually
felt that would constitute systemic
racism under a coach like that uh I mean
that I mean I'll go more in depth uh
once I do the documentary um and then
like I said I have coaches I have
players U that were there to kind of
witness some of those things um but
again it just yeah it was kind of like
how I was treated versus you know uh you
know maybe just say Garcia I mean um
those are some of the things that that I
saw like I said I don't want to give it
away here but once the documentary comes
out like I said bro I'm I'm yeah I'm an
open book bro and so again I have no
reason to lie about anything because
these are my experiences and I know for
sure like you know there was a time like
I was late for I remember this this this
particular event I was I was late for
for uh for practice one day was uh
around the time that they we were
announcing uh the proo votes um for
whatever reason I overslept and uh coach
at that time he had this policy because
according to the CBA depending on
however many infractions what they find
you this amount this amount this amount
what have you but he had one thing about
him he didn't want to take guys money so
he gave the if you got fin or you got
fin or you were late or whatever the
case may be he didn't want to find you
he gave you an opportunity to buy the
team lunch and so that was nothing like
a few hundred few hundred 800 bucks or
something like that a fine depending on
the the degree of it uh it could be up
to like I think 3,500 bucks or whatever
um and so I was late um he didn't ask me
he didn't even asked me why I was
late they always uh point a coach at the
beginning of the year uh to handle the
fines with with the guys so just so
happened that year my coach my receiver
coach happened to be the guy to to to
handle the fin so uh we had gone through
walk through uh like I said I had missed
I had missed a meeting where they
announced a proo voting uh the guys that
made the pro pro bowl and not obviously
I I had made the Pro Bowl that year and
so um he didn't ask me you know coach
okay George Stewart comes to my locker
he gives me the sheet the find and and
he fined me and it was like the maximum
and I'm like why am I getting fined I'm
like he didn't even give me the option
as the other guys to buy the team lunch
he just find me the max off the off the
rip and not on not even on that he
didn't even ask me why I was late I
could have been an offender bendor I
could have had a family emergency
anything that could have maybe excused
her being a little bit lenient as to the
find he just find me right off the bat
and so I looked at it and I told my
coach I was like I'm not I'm paying this
and I literally I immediately we had a
little back back hallway to get up to
the to the coach's office and I went
right up to the I said I'm I said coach
I'm not paying this and he said where
you going so I went and I said I'm going
to his office and he's like I'm going
with you big dog so he followed me all
the way up the stairs and there was a
reception I was like is uh much in is is
he in the office and then she left so
she called and said uh you know said I
was out front she was like send him in
and I took the paper and I said I'm not
I'm not paying this sorry about that bro
Tom you not
and I said I said I'm not paying this I
said I'm not paying this I said if I
have to pay this I will go out there and
I would tell them what I what have I
what I have have experienced up to date
if I got to pay this fine and then
shortly after that rest in peace
um um who was the
uh the coach uh he was a coach but then
he end up being the um Bill Walsh bill
was being like a consultant m I went
down to Bill washer's office and I told
him exactly what happened and he said
don't worry about he's like I'll handle
it and I didn't Bill said that too yep
and and I cuz I told him exactly what
happened and there was no reason I
didn't lie about anything and I'm like
why would I be fine and he giving
everybody else the option of buying the
team lunch and now is this the first
time you're late it doesn't matter even
if that if if it was a second first
second or third I at that time I don't
remember to your question I don't know
if it was the first CU it if I'm a coach
it would matter if you're doing it now
to punk me in front of my players and
I'm losing credibility it's very
annoying as a coach to go through it if
it is the first time and he's doing that
he's an but if it's not you may
also try to get under his skin cuz
players know how to do that as well well
again I I I knew like at that time like
media obviously they comes to the locker
and you know talking about the the
upcoming game this and that and the
other so I just like look if I got to
pay this fan I'm literally I'm going to
tell them because and I mentioned
certain events that had happened that I
experienced I'm going to say this and
I'm going to say this and then I again I
went down to coach uh at that time he
was a bill washer's office and I told
him what happened and he even said that
it wasn't right and then he said I'll
handle it I didn't end up uh having to
pay the fine but that was just one of
the insts that I that I that I that I
witness that I experienced you know you
know this this this world of of sports
like I don't know what it is to be in it
I've heard what others say you know hey
you're getting paid to play have fun
enjoy we're the luckiest people alive I
heard Denzel one one time you know said
uh about couple of the actors were
complaining about how tough it is mental
toughness attention all this stuff he's
like he says what are you talking about
we're the luckiest people alive we don't
have a job we're acting we're getting
paid to act we are the lck so there is
that mindset as well that's why I asked
the question earlier with Limelight
pressure performance personal life
getting out there doing it media
dividing you against your quarterback
because you know media's job is to get
that fire within the club the more
controversy the more conflict there is
the more stories they have to talk about
the more viewers they get the more money
the network gets the more contract they
can get they need you to have a fight
within the locker room the less fights
in the locker room the less money
they're making they want to be able to
see some some of that stuff happening so
if you're in it how do you handle that
you know if you're in that world and
you're and you're seeing it I don't know
if there's a you know who do you trust
you know do you go talk to one of your
college football coaches but by the way
who was one of your I think in one of
the clips you said your favorite guy was
Andy Reid is that is that you said Andor
yeah my favorite coach was uh yeah yeah
the best coach I've ever played for I
mean what was unique about him with you
what was the relationship like because I
think with the talent that I I felt like
I had and obviously that kind of goes to
what you guys were asking me about you
know do I think I was better than Jerry
at some point I saw the skill set and
talent that I possessed and when I went
to when I went to the
Eagles he saw because we played against
him we played against Andy and I I I
performed well against the Eagles which
is like one of the like during the time
they're one of the toughest defenses to
play against and I fed pretty well so
obviously when there was a time
obviously you know for me to uh to to
play get traded and I got got an
opportunity to play for him um I had
basically got a chance I think the year
before uh playing in the Pro Bowl
because yeah because when you lose the
NFC Championship uh The Loser coaches
the Pro Bowl yeah like it's a good and a
bad like a good and a bad good bad thing
but I didn't know that so you got think
about prior to me going to the eagles
they had lost the NFC Championship four
times four in a row and so one of those
when I one of those years like I said
the year before I got there obviously I
was playing with the Niners I made the
Pro Bowl so I got a chance to play uh
with that you know be coached by that uh
Philadelphia Eagles uh coaching staff
and so that was the first uh you know
time I got a chance to play with Donovan
and some of the some of the Eagles and
obviously he was the the coach and so um
obviously playing with him going to play
with the the Philadelphia Eagles again
he's a student of the not as just a
student of the game he's he's an
offensive guy and he saw what I was able
to do with that West Coast offense and
if you think about that West Coast
lineage and that tree he's in there with
the Moes and the homrs he's in there
he's he's good right so he was able to
basically put me in the best positions
to win and play at the highest level
that I felt like I could have played at
like I told you earlier nobody knew that
I was as fast as I was especially until
I got to Philadelphia then after
Philadelphia because everything that I
did within the offense of San Francisco
post uh Steve Young with with with Jeff
Garcia it was the short intermediate
routes and then and then I took it the
distance I wasn't catching a lot of bums
I wasn't catching a lot of go routes it
wasn't until I got there that people saw
well he noticed and realized that I
could do those things and so he put me
in the best I I played in 21 games and I
had 20
touchdowns sick so so that that puts it
in perspective for you and so then I
went to Dallas again I had like I played
that three years and I know this because
people tell me all these stats I had 38
touchdowns in the three years that I was
there it's almost like 10 a year so
again it was like I was playing and I
was efficient it's like a shooter you're
you're you're performing at a high
efficiency uh and I was scoring like on
a regular like it was I would talk to my
friends or on the way or my mom or my
brother on the way to games I would tell
them like how many touchdowns that I
felt like I was going to score sick and
Donovan had an arm right he had a rifle
again yeah that was the strongest armed
quarterback that I I had played with um
he was he was the strongest armed
quarterback that makes sense was he most
accurate No No but he put it on there
but he didn't need to be with you but
again it just shows you the type of
quarterback that I played with versus
not makes sense Tom Andy Reid where do
you put him is he the best coach right
now in the NFL I I think so I mean you
take a
look crickle pointed out you know the
Bill W coaching tree Shanahan two Super
Bowls Reed two Super Bowls holgren won
Super Bowl I think right now you look
around he is the last of a important
generation he and probably bill bich
yeah for sure bill yeah that generation
and then you have some guys coming up
you know in San Francisco you get the
Sun coming up but you but I I would say
right now if I was drafting a team right
now and uh could choose your quarterback
could you your coach it be him I I would
choose Andy Reid I'm wow hand on the
Bible I would choose Andy Reid my
quarterback right now I mean my as my as
my coach right now he also gets along
well with a variety of general managers
and that chemistry has why is that
though I mean because because because
look athletes there's drama there's
attention you need you need one-on-one
attention you need them to know how
important you are they need to be
believed in you need to know how to
challenge them you need to know how to
have tough conversations with them how
did he balance that with with players
and coaches and GMS I don't know I think
it just comes with the the sport itself
and then again how you're groomed how
you're how you're being taught yeah I
mean I think yeah those things are are
are very obvious and evident you to
coaches with his amount of success um
especially when you're surrounded with
success and you're watching how they go
about you know coaching and how they're
dealing with different uh players
different personalities or what have you
he was around that for a number of years
because again he was at Green Bay um
like I said that that West Coast that
that tree of of coaches and he mentioned
a number of them it it's it's
fascinating even like I said even
maruchi all these guys are are are are
part of that that that lineage and part
of that that that tree um but again like
I said when you think about you know um
Andy Reid like he was challenge you
behind how did he challenge you behind
did he ever have tough conversations
with you no I cuz I was a breath of
fresh air like honestly when I went to
to the so zero conflict with the two of
you guys the only issue we had was when
I went there uh I was used to wearing
tights in practice Yeah that's how I
watched Jerry do it uh for a number of
years and so I adopted you know even the
receivers we adopted you know that's how
we practice we practic in our tights I
went there and I went outside the first
practice and with my tight I had black
tit
tonone the equipment guy sent me back in
he said go get your shorts and I'm like
what do you mean I'm like this is how I
practice and he was like no Andy wants
you to put shorts on I'm like what so
I'm like in my mind I'm looking at that
picture and I'm looking at Andy I'm like
is he jealous of my body or something
like like why does he want me to go put
my why does he want me to go put shorts
on by the way they don't make tights
that size no so let me tell y'all a
funny so let let me tell you a funny let
me tell you special order only let me
tell you a funny story the world almost
got to see him in a pair of tights no
uhoh was a bet yes so I so for eight
years that's all I've ever known like
aside from my first couple of years
rookie what I wore my shorts and
training camp this and that but then I
adopt I saw Jerry do it like he would
wear his T and practice whatever warmed
up and and everything so again just told
you story they sent me back in to get my
shorts I was h I was lowkey mad I'm like
cuz it just felt like I I was in a I
felt like I was in a good mood I was in
a great situation I'm looking to come
here and like really like play and you
know help this team get to the Super
Bowl and then it was just like it was
just that was a damper on my day so I
went in and I put shorts on and I'm
looking I was reluctantly putting those
shorts on and I went back out and so we
end up having a conversation about the
Titans and he saw he saw my energy go
down and we talked about in off he said
you really want he said you really want
to wear not wear those shorts huh and I
like I said coach I said this is what
I've known I said the greatest receiver
of all time this is how we practice so
this is what I've always known I'm like
it's not that I I just don't feel
comfortable he said let's he said and uh
he said uh let's he said let's uh let's
let's make a bet let's let's place a
little wager on this and I said cool and
uh he said how many touchdowns did you
have this this the last year what I I
don't know know and then and I think the
most touchdowns I think a eagle receiver
has had I think it was like I think it
was from not I think it may have been 14
or something I think that's how many I
had in San Francisco leaving there and
he said do you think you'll get 14 here
I said yeah for sure and he said no he
said no receivers ever had that many
touchdowns and he said I said okay cool
I said so if I if I beat that he said I
can wear my tights uh he said yeah and I
said if I beat it I said you got to we
some
TI and so he was like okay cool so it
was a bet so I left it what it was when
I got hurt I was at 14 get out of here
oh my God get out of here I was what a
great story so you know in his mind he's
like I love
you well listen on behalf of fans we
want to thank you I spared the
world I Spar the world Spar the world I
spared the world but honestly I was so I
was I didn't think about it to later but
I was living I'm like oh my I was like I
was at 14 by the way did he let you wear
the tights the rest of the season or you
couldn't do was yours yeah it wasn't my
dude I I had to wear dude I had to wear
well yeah your Peak on pregame warm-ups
my wife and I saw you on pregame
warm-ups and I said take a look at that
how if you're a corner do you not say to
yourself that is a human being I got to
come yeah forget it this is San
Francisco you're saying yeah we would
see it I I've heard so many stories of
me working uh because that was my routin
that's probably the PG-13 story there's
probably some rated R stories no no I
don't have any I mean that was just like
my my this was like my pregame routine
and then obviously like I said there
were some women reporters that I've come
across like I said there was the all
white that I had I had uh that I had
worn that became a topic of discussion
with a lot of people but pull the all
whites let's see what I didn't but I
didn't know ask question I didn't know
anything about this prame did this
pregame include cas usually running past
defense
stretching I would watch where you you
would have routes all over the open
field I you made sure they could see
every ounce of what they got to defend
right I always ran I always took a full
lap around the field always a full left
around the field and the defense is
stretching in the end zone and you're
just cruising by and I've heard I've
heard some player that's like oh my God
I heard I've heard some coaches you know
go to their DB they look that's what
y'all got a C that's a good tactic
that's good by the way shout out to uh
Andy Reid he was an offensive tackle at
glendel Community College Tom did you
know that he was an offensive tackle at
the GCC anyways this he was so he wasn't
tight W listen long time ago that's look
at it right there he was a he he played
for BYU but before BYU he was a GCC as
an offensive tackle uh too it's been an
absolute uh uh pleasure to have you on
gang if you're watching this we have the
winner for some the person that asked
the question answer the question the
question was what Rob the question was
uh who was ter I'm sorry owens's
favorite QB yes during his career the
options were Steve Young Jeff Garcia
Ryan Fitzpatrick Donovan McNab or Tony
Romo the answer answer is uh Ryan
Fitzpatrick which was guessed correctly
by Paul galushkin who paulin's a good
guy Paul Paul that's right he's a good
guy man good for you Paul you're going
to be getting this ball sent over your
by the way for those you guys that are
watching this and you have questions for
to you want to ask him questions about
career maybe you got kids that going to
college maybe you want to ask him about
you know you're in the game you want to
ask them questions Financial contracts
lawy whatever it may be any kind of
questions you have you can ask those
questions of too on man uh Rob if you
can put the link below for man and then
on top of that last but not least Tio do
you mind telling us about these candles
before we wrap up yeah so early I I I
talked about like which I call my three
pillars of success which are my three DS
desire dedication and discipline so I
designated so all the scents are
dedicated to these candles so there's a
scent for desire there's a scent for
dedication and there's a scent for for
discipline and then there's a fourth one
that I added I have five but the fourth
one that that I added was during the
pandemic um everybody was shifting and
pivoting and doing things and so I got
in the wine space and so I have a wine
under the Tommy Lort Lort family wines
label uh which is called 81 and so the
ingredients with that it has cockadoo
Plum and some other things uh in it and
so we had so we made a a wine pairing
candle um to pair with the wine and so
obviously like I said with uh with h
with the candles um there with desire so
I was very instrumental with my partner
uh business partner Carolyn tayor she
had an existing company and she knew
everybody that knows me personally they
know that I like home decor um I love
fashion which is part of why I got into
the the clothing line business as well
as like my mom she was a seamstress
growing up but as it relates to the the
the candles everywhere that I've been I
always had bought candles you know I
just it was just like uh just an
accessory and then like said you like to
have your house smell smell inviting
especially when you have guests and all
those things so uh she asked me would I
want to be a partner in it and I'm like
sure so we came up with a loft 81 home
um obviously the the the brand and then
with these candles we we started out
with desire which is made up of a a
cashmere vanilla a dark labdanum rose
and a saffron tobacco oh wow saffron
tobacco Middle Eastern so we love that
respect right so that's that's desire so
I wanted something obviously to that's
that's that's SE that smells sexy you
know what I mean that's not overpowering
this light and so when you think about
the cashmere vanilla it kind of softens
uh softens some of those uh those
ingredients up and then uh dedication
it's made uh it's made up of a uh sage
and lavender uh the same D dark lab Dam
Rose and then uh uh Rose Puli and and
Amber well listen the way you said it
bro I want to order a kiss you sound
like a candle
scientist and so the candles are made
with intention everything is about about
intention it's about mindset so
everything that I've done like I said
there's like I said it it infuses the
desire and the dedication and the
discipline in in in it and so when even
with the box with the uh with the Box
you see here um I was very instrumental
with with uh the texture you got the
embossed logo here and then this a
little tab right here it says pull with
intent so again obviously you can use
these candles uh the boxes as well once
the candles are are are burned uh but
yeah that's uh that's that's pretty much
how I got in I got involved with it and
like I said we want to sign we want to
sell a lot more candles we want to
obviously get in some retail uh stores
or what have you um we again it's simple
uh it's simplic and uh yeah and then the
last one is discipline uh discipline is
like you know kind of the mindset you
burn this kind of when you want to you
know get in a mindset if you want to
just go to the gym and you want to just
meditate or just kind of just get deep
in your thoughts like for me I just
think about like my my offseason
training if I'm just like I once I
started training in April of every after
of every offseason whatever I was doing
within the the months of my last last
game up until April I just kind of just
let myself go kind of gave myself kind
of chance to just re uh unwind I let my
body healed but soon as April hit that
first week in April I was back on grind
yeah I was back on Grind Mode nothing
nothing nothing else mattered but
preparing myself for the upcoming season
so so desire it's made up of a a I mean
a discipline it's made up of a a merry
gold uh and a cedar musk and then a
woody a woody leather and
Brandy brother I've never met anybody
this this detailed with candles we
officially I'm telling you he's got a
nickname it's the to you may have a lot
of nicknames you're the candle scientist
uh place an order for candles if you're
a candles person I got a candle on my
office upstairs I got to go replace it
with one of these now loft 81h home.com
loft 81h home.com the Link's going to be
below as well gang uh uh to again one
can I do one more go for cuz this is for
my Grandmama go for it um we uh every
month uh well not every month but in
June uh and November is uh Alzheimer's
mental health and Alzheimer's Awareness
Month in June is mental health um but in
in November it's Alzheimer's awareness
uh month and so my Grandmama passed in
2012 uh to alzheimer's um in 200000 I
spoke before Congress to help with
obviously bring bringing awareness and
obviously increase funding for the
disease and so we partner with
Alzheimer's Association so we have a
candle I have a candle uh dedicated to
my grandma because I remember I told you
she was she was very very strict so this
cand respect right it's called tough
love uh so if it's in a purple uh the uh
the month it's not one of those but one
of those uh so the month is purple you
know how um breast cancer is is pink or
whatever so we're using a we got a
purple vase um for for the candle uh
yeah so if you y so you go to Loft 81
home you obviously you'll see respect
and respect for that so tough love so
and tough love so to come up with the
scent with that I you I I I came up with
something that obviously that made me
think about like a Grandmama which is
like you know dried uh Floral
and incense you know something along
those Natures so when I grew up when you
think Grandma you think floral something
blah blah blah so that's what I that's
what we have it and then the cashmere
Plum kind of softens it up a little bit
so honestly this probably the one that
has the most potent throw when I think
about Grandma I think about Bill Withers
the song Grandma's hands I don't know if
you know that song song or not but it's
an old school hand okay Tio blast having
with you here having you on the podcast
I'll put all those link below gang have
a great day we'll do this again tomorrow
2:30 live take care everybody bye-bye
bye-bye